>> Will Sentance: Có chức năng tạo người dùng của chúng tôi,
thông báo không tạo một đối tượng bên trong nó.
Không tạo liên kết với một số cửa hàng hoặc chức năng được chia sẻ, không trả lại một đối tượng.
Bởi vì chúng tôi sẽ chạy chức năng đó với sự trợ giúp của cái mới,
chúng ta có thể gọi đó là một bổ ngữ.
Nó thay đổi hành vi của bối cảnh thực thi người tạo người dùng,
nó sẽ tự động chèn nội dung vào đó cho chúng tôi khi chúng tôi chạy nó.
Nhưng chờ đợi, chúng ta cần một kho lưu trữ chung các chức năng, một chức năng đồng.
Bạn nói gì, một phiên bản lưu của các chức năng đó.
Làm thế nào để chúng ta chắc chắn rằng chúng ta có một mối quan hệ với họ?
Chà, hóa ra hàm tạo người dùng cũng là một đối tượng,
tổ hợp đối tượng chức năng.
Đó là những gì một chức năng, chúng tôi chỉ không nói về đối tượng nhưng hầu hết thời gian.
Và bit đối tượng của nó có một thuộc tính được gọi là nguyên mẫu thành
mà chúng tôi sẽ lưu trữ và phương pháp tăng dần
Hãy đi qua mọi người, ở đây chúng ta đi từng dòng một.
Jeff, nếu bạn không phiền hãy mang nó đi thực sự với một loại hoàn chỉnh
mô tả như bộ nhớ chung.
Jeff, mô tả đầy đủ về những gì chúng tôi đang làm trong dòng đầu tiên đó
hơn là chỉ khai báo một hàm, phải không?
Chúng ta đang làm gì vậy?
>> Người nói 2: Chúng tôi đang tạo một nhãn có tên là người tạo người dùng.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, đó là một định nghĩa hàm đã lưu trữ nó, nhưng
gì nữa?
>> Người nói 2: Điều đó ngầm có một đối tượng.
>> Will Sentance: Tôi không bận tâm về từ ngầm ở đó, vâng,
nó có nó là một tổ hợp đối tượng chức năng, như tôi muốn gọi nó.
Đây rồi, nó có cả khai báo hàm hoặc định nghĩa hàm xin lỗi,
đó là sự kết hợp của một chức năng với một đối tượng.
Đó là những gì chúng tôi đang làm khi xác định một hàm.
Chúng tôi không nói về điều này hầu hết thời gian, nhưng nó luôn ở đó.
Được rồi, bây giờ, chúng tôi vẫn chưa hoàn thành.
Adam, đối tượng này không phải là một đối tượng rỗng.
Đó là một đối tượng, thuộc tính nào trên nó?
>> Will Sentance: Vấn đề là nó tự động hướng tới điều gì?
>> Adam: Nguyên mẫu. >> Will Sentance: Nguyên mẫu, và Adam,
tài sản nguyên mẫu đó được lưu trữ trong một cái cũ lớn là gì?
>> Adam: Đối tượng rỗng.
>> Will Sentance: Đối tượng trống, vì vậy
đây thực sự là những gì chúng tôi đang làm chỉ trong định nghĩa hàm của chúng tôi.
Chúng tôi không thường xuyên nói về vấn đề này nhưng
nó ở đó, chức năng, tổ hợp đối tượng.
Và đối tượng đó có một thuộc tính gọi là nguyên mẫu, bản thân nó là một đối tượng cũ lớn
được lưu trữ trên đó.
Làm cách nào để truy cập đối tượng này?
Dan, tôi viết loại từ gì để nói đến đối tượng ở đây?
>> Dan: Creator.prototype.
>> Will Sentance: Usercished.prototype, và điều đó sẽ cung cấp cho tôi đối tượng.
Nếu tôi muốn lưu trữ một cái gì đó trong đối tượng đó Dan, tôi sẽ viết gì?
Usercreator- >> Dan: .prototype.-
>> Will Sentance: Dù nhãn sẽ thế nào
hãy vì điều đó chính xác.
Tôi e rằng chúng ta sẽ đi.
Ở đây chúng ta tiếp tục ghi chú đó, Dan, chúng ta đang làm gì ở đây
bởi vì chúng tôi sẽ sử dụng đối tượng này giống như cách sử dụng một cửa hàng chức năng đối với
một phiên bản lưu vert duy nhất của mỗi chức năng.
Rằng chúng tôi muốn bất kỳ đối tượng nào được trả về sau khi chạy
người tạo người dùng có quyền truy cập vào bất kỳ chức năng nào được lưu trữ ở đây.
Và Dan, những gì chúng ta sẽ lưu trữ đã dạy cho tôi qua từng từ một,
từ trái sang phải.
>> Dan: Chúng tôi đang tìm kiếm người tạo người dùng.
Chúng tôi sẽ đến nguyên mẫu.
>> Will Sentance: Chà, tôi sẽ không sử dụng nguyên mẫu nhưng
nó nghe như một cái gì đó kỳ diệu.
>> Dan: Chúng ta sẽ đến phần- >> Will Sentance: Người dùng tạo đối tượng
phiên bản của chính nó, một phần đối tượng của chính nó mà chúng ta tìm kiếm, thuộc tính nào trên đó?
>> Dan: Nguyên mẫu- >> Di chúc: Hoàn toàn,
mà chúng tôi tìm thấy là một?
>> Dan: Vật trống >> Lời di chúc: Cảm ơn trời đất,
bởi vì những gì chúng tôi cố gắng và làm tiếp theo, chúng tôi cố gắng?
>> Dan: Tạo gia số nhãn mới.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, trong đối tượng đó-
>> Dan: Và lưu trữ một hàm.
>> Will Sentance: Thành thật mà nói tôi biết để làm điều này trong
loại phiên bản thu âm này, nhưng điều đó xứng đáng được một tràng pháo tay.
Cảm ơn bạn, Dan. Điều đó rất, rất tốt.
>> [VỖ TAY] >> Di chúc: Tốt đẹp từ Dan.
Hãy để Ethan làm phần tiếp theo ở đây.
Vì vậy, tìm kiếm người tạo người dùng, Ethan?
>> Ethan: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Nhận thấy rằng đó là một hàm cộng với một đối tượng,
chúng ta sẽ truy cập bit chức năng của nó ở đây hay bit đối tượng của nó ở đây?
>> Ethan: Đối tượng.
>> Will Sentance: Đối tượng bit, sử dụng ký hiệu dấu chấm, và
nó có một thuộc tính trên đối tượng được gọi là?
>> Ethan: Nguyên mẫu. >> Di chúc: Bản thân nó,
cảm ơn trời, một đối tượng, bởi vì chúng tôi sẽ cố gắng và
làm những gì với đối tượng nguyên mẫu đó.
Chúng tôi sẽ thử và chỉ định nó?
>> Ethan: Và đăng nhập nhãn.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, khi đăng nhập thuộc tính và gán cho nó một chức năng,
một phương pháp.
Nhìn kìa, mọi người, hãy nhìn vào đó,
đó là kho lưu trữ phiên bản duy nhất của các chức năng của chúng tôi.
Được rồi, tốt.
Bây giờ chuyển xuống dòng tiếp theo.
Braydon, bên tay trái.
Đó là câu nói gì? Chờ đã, để tôi làm bên tay trái.
Braden, nói gì để làm?
>> Braydon: Đừng khai báo một người dùng cố định.
>> Will Sentance: Khai báo một người dùng không đổi.
Chúng ta có biết những gì cần lưu trữ trong đó không, Braydon?
>> Braydon: Không chỉ- >> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi không biết.
Đừng bao giờ nhìn vào từ khóa mới đó và
nghĩ bằng cách nào đó người dùng một cái này khác với một hàm.
Chúng ta đang làm gì ở phía bên tay phải, Brayden?
Giữ cái mới bây giờ, bạn đã làm gì ở bên tay phải?
>> Braydon: Bạn đang gọi người tạo người dùng
>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi đang gọi,
chúng tôi đang thực hiện, chúng tôi đang chạy chức năng tạo người dùng với Prince.
Không có gì ma thuật, không có gì khác biệt, không có gì đối tượng,
nghĩa đen chỉ là gọi người tạo người dùng.
Với một từ gồm ba chữ cái đặc biệt phía trước sẽ làm được rất nhiều thứ
bên trong ngữ cảnh thực thi của người tạo người dùng.
Được rồi, hiện tại, user1 của chúng ta là, Brayden?
>> Braydon: Chưa được làm sạch.
>> Will Sentance: Chưa khởi tạo, vâng, hoàn hảo.
Được rồi, chúng ta đi thôi.
Đây là tác phẩm cuối cùng, cuối cùng, mọi người.
Được rồi, người tạo người dùng, tôi sẽ sử dụng màu xanh lam cho nội dung mới của mình.
Vì vậy, có cách gọi mới,
như thường lệ, gọi hàm.
Chỉ với một chút thay đổi nhỏ,
về những gì nó sẽ làm bên trong bối cảnh thực thi.
Nó sẽ tự động hóa rất nhiều thứ bên trong ngữ cảnh thực thi đó.
Gọi userCreator bằng Eva, và 9.
Tôi nghĩ đó gần như là cơ hội cuối cùng của chúng tôi để làm điều này.
Đó là một thương hiệu, nó là một thương hiệu mới?
>> Diễn giả 2: Bối cảnh thực thi.
>> Will Sentance: Bối cảnh thực thi, nghe có vẻ tuyệt vời.
Đây rồi, nó rất lớn.
Đây rồi, tôi vẫn vậy, một ngày nào đó tôi sẽ giỏi việc đó.
Đây rồi, bối cảnh thực thi khổng lồ.
Intuit bạn đi, vâng, Intuit chúng tôi đi,
và, >> Thư Di chúc: Tại địa phương của chúng tôi,
>> Will Sentance: Ký ức.
Đầu tiên, hãy xử lý các tổ hợp đối số tham số của chúng ta.
Peter, của chúng tôi, đầu vào cho chức năng này, là gì?
>> Peter: Eva- >> Will Sentance: Hãy làm điều đó trước.
Eva, và nó được gán cho tham số nào, trình giữ chỗ nào bên trong hàm?
>> Peter: Tên. >> Di chúc: Tên, chính xác.
Đừng nghĩ đây là các đối tượng, thuộc tính, hoặc nhân tiện,
bất cứ điều gì liên quan đến từ khóa mới là đầu vào thường xuyên cho hàm.
Người tiếp theo, Peter một lần nữa?
>> Peter: Điểm là 9.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, tham số điểm là đối số của giá trị 9.
Điều đó giống như nếu chúng ta khai báo các biến bên trong hàm này.
Chúng tôi chỉ có thể viết bên trong ở đây, tôi không biết, tên const cũng vậy.
Nhưng chúng tôi không muốn làm cho nó trở nên không chung chung, [LAUGH] không linh hoạt.
Chúng tôi muốn có thể thay đổi nó mỗi khi chúng tôi chạy chức năng này, được không?
Đó là, bút trắng xuống, bút xanh.
Toàn bộ điểm của chức năng này, bất cứ điều gì chúng ta đang làm ở đây là tạo ra những gì,
Braydon?
>> Braydon: Một đối tượng.
>> Will Sentance: Một đối tượng.
Chúng ta có muốn phải khai báo thủ công một đối tượng mỗi khi bạn thực hiện một hàm không
điều đó làm được điều này?
Không, vậy từ khóa mới của chúng ta là gì?
Điều đầu tiên nó sẽ làm, Braydon?
>> Braydon: Chỉ định đối tượng trống.
>> Will Sentance: Ừ, khai báo và lưu vào bộ nhớ.
Một đối tượng trống rỗng.
Chúng tôi muốn có quyền truy cập để có thể đưa nội dung vào đó.
Nhãn chúng tôi đã cấp để truy cập nó là gì, Braydon?
>> Braydon: Cái này. >> Will Sentance: Cái này, chính xác là đẹp,
đặt điều này thành đối tượng trống.
Đẹp.
Được rồi.
Nhưng chúng tôi sẽ không phản đối khi nó cuối cùng được trả lại cho người dùng một
để có quyền truy cập vào phiên bản lưu duy nhất của các chức năng của chúng tôi.
Chúng tôi muốn nó có quyền truy cập để ghi nhớ, toàn bộ mục tiêu của chúng tôi ở đây.
Vì vậy, tôi có thể làm điều này bằng cách sử dụng một số gia tăng nhỏ.
Đó là mục tiêu duy nhất của cả hội thảo.
Biểu tượng có chức năng áp dụng cho người dùng đó không,
không phải trên toàn bộ 100.000 dòng mã, nhưng
thay vào đó, ngay tại đó trên người dùng của chúng tôi một đối tượng.
Không được chia sẻ bởi tất cả các câu hỏi đố trong các bảng giải đấu, không.
Ngay tại đó, trên đối tượng user1 của chúng tôi, đó là mục tiêu duy nhất của chúng tôi.
Nhưng biết rằng chúng ta không thể lưu trữ trực tiếp hàm gia tăng trên đối tượng đó,
thay vào đó chúng tôi muốn có một liên kết thông qua tham chiếu proto của nó.
>> Will Sentance: kho chức năng được chia sẻ này.
Và Braydon, bạn nghĩ thuộc tính proto ẩn của họ sẽ liên kết đến điều gì?
Hãy rất cụ thể, chính xác ở đâu?
>> Braydon: Nó sẽ liên kết với phần đối tượng của
chức năng của người tạo người dùng đối với thuộc tính nguyên mẫu.
>> Will Sentance: Chính nó là gì?
>> Braydon: Một đối tượng.
>> Will Sentance: Một đối tượng, có đầy đủ các chức năng mà chúng tôi đã đưa vào đó.
Rất, rất, rất tốt ở đó, được Braydon đánh giá cao.
Từ Brayden ở đó, cho đến vật thể đó, thật tuyệt vời.
Được rồi, bây giờ chúng ta quay lại với chúng ta.
Vì vậy, đó là điều thứ hai nó làm, đặt proto cho chức năng đang được chạy,
vào thuộc tính nguyên mẫu của phiên bản đối tượng của nó, bản thân nó là một đối tượng.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi đặt proto thành userCreate hoặc
bất kể chức năng là gì, đây là từ khóa mới .prototype.
Tất cả đều được tự động hóa bởi từ khóa mới cho chúng tôi.
Cái này trông khá đẹp phải không?
Nhưng bây giờ chúng ta phải lấy một số dữ liệu cụ thể thực tế.
Dan, gửi cho bạn >> Dan: Chúng tôi chạy dòng tên ngăn xếp,
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời.
>> Dan: Chúng tôi thêm cái này vào bộ nhớ cục bộ, >> Will Sentance: Yeah.
>> Dan: Và tạo một tên nhãn mới cho thấy rằng tên-
>> Will Sentance: Tôi sẽ nói ở đây,
bởi vì chúng tôi không muốn bị nhầm lẫn
với >> Dan: Yeah.
>> Will Sentance: Tên hoặc tham số biến, tên thuộc tính mới và
do tôi chọn rất vô ích, sẽ thành công, Dan?
>> Dan: Cuộc tranh luận đã được thông qua.
>> Will Sentance: Đó là?
Tuyệt diệu.
Nhân tiện, Dan cộng đồng kỹ thuật của bạn rất xuất sắc.
Và sau đó là dòng tiếp theo?
>> Dan: Tương tự như vậy nhưng với điểm số về điều này- >> Will Sentance: Tự động tạo
với sự trợ giúp của từ khóa mới, từ khóa đã có nhãn?
>> Dan: Cái này. >> Di chúc: Đây, chính xác, và
chúng tôi đi đến nó và chúng tôi tìm thấy nó có thuộc tính điểm không?
>> Dan: Không. >> Will Sentance: Không, vậy
chúng tôi làm cho nó, nó đây.
Và chúng tôi đã chỉ định nó, cái gì, Dan?
>> Dan: 9. >> Di chúc: Giá trị của trường học
tham số là đối số là chính sách, chính xác là 9.
Dân gian đó là một khá tốt đẹp, đó chính xác là những gì chúng tôi muốn.
Nhưng nó bị kẹt bên trong một chức năng, bên trong trình tạo người dùng của chúng tôi,
và tôi đang xem xét người tạo người dùng, tôi không thấy bất kỳ thứ gì được trả lại.
What Mark, bạn có nghĩ rằng điều cuối cùng mà từ khóa mới của chúng tôi tự động hóa không?
>> Dan: Trả lại cái này.
>> Will Sentance: Hãy nhớ rằng, trả lại điều này, chính xác là đúng.
Trả lại đối tượng được chỉ định cho từ khóa này,
Tôi cũng thích làm điều đó với màu xanh lam, phải không?
Bởi vì nó tự động, đưa nó trở lại nhãn chung.
Toàn bộ phần này ở đây đánh giá sẽ biến thành đối tượng trả về và
được lưu trữ vào những gì?
Chuyển thành user1 với tên,
thật buồn cười khi tôi đã thay đổi
màu sắc, không hữu ích.
Chúng ta đi rồi, bạn thân mến, vâng,
với thuộc tính proto ẩn của chúng tôi__proto
gạch dưới là một liên kết đến userCreator.product
đối tượng lớn này cho các chức năng được chia sẻ.
Được rồi, bây giờ bối cảnh thực thi ở đây, ở lại hay đi?
Chính xác là đã xuất hiện từ chỉ số cuộc gọi.
Chúng tôi không hiển thị chỉ số cuộc gọi, nhưng nó đã bị xóa và
bây giờ chúng tôi kiểm tra tất cả các quan trọng của chúng tôi.
Điều duy nhất chúng tôi thực sự quan tâm trong suốt thời gian qua.
Nếu tôi có thể làm user1.increment.
Và nhân tiện mọi người, đây là lý do tại sao tôi muốn nói với bạn giải pháp hai, đã làm được việc.
Giải pháp ba chỉ là tự động hóa rất nhiều công việc đó đối với chúng tôi, điều này thật tuyệt vời.
Nhưng dưới mui xe, nó hoàn toàn giống nhau, về cách làm giống hệt nhau.
Có, nó phải thực hiện một vài thay đổi nhỏ.
Chúng ta phải đặt tất cả các chức năng của mình vào đối tượng này, vì chúng ta không kiểm soát được nó.
Vì vậy, tốt hơn chúng ta nên đặt nó ở một nơi nào đó mà JavaScript biết chúng sẽ đến.
Chúng tôi đã có cái này làm nhãn cho đối tượng.
Nhưng nếu không, nó hoàn toàn giống nhau.
Ngoài ra, chúng ta có thể làm điều này.
Đặt các chức năng và dữ liệu của chúng ta cùng nhau để chúng ta dễ dàng lập luận, nhưng
chúng ta không thể có các hàm theo nghĩa đen trên đối tượng.
Nếu không, tôi đã được sao chép trên mọi đối tượng người dùng, người dùng một, người dùng hai,
người dùng 500.
Chúng tôi lãng phí không gian bộ nhớ.
Vì vậy, thay vào đó, chúng tôi có chúng ở một nơi duy nhất một phiên bản lưu.
Và tính năng proto của nguyên mẫu Java sẽ có JavaScript.
Đó là thuộc tính proto mà tất cả các đối tượng đều có.
Chúng tôi thiết lập nó để liên kết với đối tượng đó, biết rằng khi JavaScript
chạy user1.increment và nó có hoạt động tốt không, hãy cùng xem.
Todd, đó là khoảnh khắc của bạn.
User1 chúng ta tìm kiếm nó ở đâu?
>> Todd: Bộ nhớ toàn cầu.
>> Will Sentance: Bộ nhớ toàn cầu, có ở đó không?
>> Todd: Vâng. >> Will Sentance: Vâng, nó là, gia tăng.
Chúng tôi nhìn vào, tốt, bạn cho tôi biết?
>> Todd: Không phải ở đó.
>> Will Sentance: [LAUGH] Good- >> Todd: [LAUGH]
>> Will Sentance: Xếp hàng một đối tượng,
không có ở đó. Chúng ta có hoảng sợ không?
>> Todd: Không. >> Will Sentance: JavaScript làm gì
tự động?
>> Todd: Nó sẽ cần đến proto, nó sẽ phụ thuộc vào người tạo người dùng
đối tượng và thuộc tính nguyên mẫu trong đối tượng đó, và nhìn vào đó.
>> Will Sentance: Hoàn toàn xuất sắc, và tìm thấy?
>> Todd: Sự gia tăng. >> Di chúc: Sự gia tăng, và
sau đó chúng tôi lấy mã đó và chúng tôi xây dựng bối cảnh thực thi.
Tuyệt vời, hãy giúp Todd một tay, Todd rất tốt.
Đó đối với tôi là một chút khó khăn nhất.
Tuyệt vời, mọi người.
Vậy là xong, một từ khóa mới đã bán được ít nhất một số vấn đề về đánh máy của chúng ta,
nhưng Chúa ơi,